This is where the blood offloads the carbon dioxide it carried away from the cells
and picks up the oxygen the cells will need to do their work.
The alveoli.
How many are there?
300 million, 600 or 800 million?
Opinions differ.
Their surface area is roughly 70 to 90 square meters.
50 times that of the human body.
Will you look at that?
Such a great place to jog, is it?
Have you seen the air we're breathing?
Not to mention the clouds of dust that rise at every step.
And I thought I'd done something right for once.
Jumbo.
Be lucky, boys.
So, better be careful.
Human body is well armed against viruses and bacteria when it's in good condition.
Enough excuses, O Fossil.
We clever viruses will show you how to get in.
You viruses are small.
You might be able to pass through unnoticed, but we bacteria can't do that.
Through the mouth, you might have a better chance because it's not so well pre-
Enough muttering.
What's this old idiot got to say, then?
He suggests avoiding the nose when we go into the human body.
He says it's very well protected, whereas the mouth is much easier to get through.
Keep your stupid advice, we are much cleverer than that.
Yeah, yeah, don't stint us, do they?
There's something I can do for you.
Nothing to worry about, my dear.
You were blown there by that sneeze.
Thing, will you?
Yes, keep out all unwelcome intruders.
The oxygen bubbles are welcome in here, my dear.
You can't complain of being cold anymore.
Very funny.
That we're being warmed up, your body.
Never to play hooky, do you?
Now you've missed your bath by coming in through the mouth?
I think that's any way for an oxygen bubble to behave.
It's a fun.
It or wasn't I?
Did you see any danger?
None.
Any defenses?
No.
It was a real walkover.
Like I said, so aren't I clever.
Gee, isn't it bad?
Because we went through the mouth and not through the nose like the old fellow told us to.
Utter nonsense.
That's got nothing at all to do with it.
We have all the weapons we can possibly need.
Listen carefully.
They are terrified of our toxic pistols.
Now, this is what we will do.
In a few minutes, we will be in contact with the population,
so it's essential that you know what your jobs are.
Certainly taking their time.
Really good.
It looks as if we'll be having a bit of fun soon.
Come on, come on, come on, get a move on.
What are you waiting for?
Well, perhaps you'd like us to come and get you, huh?
Now that's an idea.
Hello, hello, Lieutenant Jumbo.
This is Antibody Major Metro.
Our friends seem unable to make up their minds to move.
Suppose we go and help them along a bit.
What do you say, Lieutenant?
Our job in the tonsils is to weed out intruders,
and this is where we are most effective.
So kindly stay at your post, Metro.
Wait for the enemy. Do you understand?
Well, that's a fine way to talk to me, I must say.
Is that all the thanks I'm going to get?
It's just not fair, is it?
Well, Officer, message received.
No need for you to get excited.
We will wait. It's okay.
Well, I mean to say on one tiny condition,
just a formality you will let us have the first assault on the enemy agreed that metro squad do
not attack the first wave of the enemy over and out now we'll meet up with them mingle and attack
have you got it right then forward everyone very good just a little bit further my friends that
will do now everyone mitosis let's split in two good now it's my turn and that was only the
In the beginning, wait until we find a quiet place, and then we really will multiply!
Ha ha ha ha!
Multiply!
Then we'll show them what we're made of!
Ah!
See, there in the lungs is where they really need all that oxygen we carry.
Because there in the middle of all those cells is where the real breathing in the human body takes place.
That's where oxygen is transformed into carbon dioxide.
Didn't hear.
They be doing.
Last, get up and pull yourselves together.
Well, what happened down there?
Did you get through?
Didn't get through the defenses!
You mean defenses? Answer me, will you?
I mean the tonsils back there!
The impregnable fortress!
They were all exterminated, Chief! Almost all!
Ugh!
Those stupid, dumb, bungling fools!
So that's it!
Well, we'll show them a thing or two, won't we?
We'll get in this way, do you understand?
Why, sir?
Hey, Chief!
Follow me, you'll see.
Interferon, cell 17067. We're under attack.
This is interferon, cell 17083, echo virus attack.
Cell 17101, echo virus is positively identified.
Manufacture antibodies.
Here we go again. There is never, ever any peace with these cells.
It's like a never-ending circus down here.
Chromosome headquarters, haven't you heard the news yet?
Well, we're under a serious virus attack.
You'd better get to work and manufacture millions of antibodies.
Hmm.
The very best place to be.
See here, there are no police.
Almost none, so we'll behave like ghosts.
Lend into the wall, melt into the crowds, and as soon as we find a good spot, we'll show them what we can do.
Attention, Site B Patrol, follow me.
Look at those fitness fanatics, what drips they are.
Yeah, show them what a real man looks like, now this is a chest.
Simple, I can also do it.
That's right, go on!
That is, look around you, lungs are a one-way street, everything comes in but nothing.
Those rocks are piles of dirt, very dirty in here if the person is breathing in polluted
air or dust.
However, there is what you could call a convenience, so we're going to meet up with those red blood
corpuscles there, and they'll take us to wherever we are needed.
Worry I'm used to it now.
Ha ha ha ha.
Let's not waste time, the body never stops breathing.
Come on children, they're waiting for us.